[Music]
many actors and other creatives depend
on copyright to make a living
it's organized nationally the rights to
a movie for instance need to be bought
in every country where it is shown
Europeans are increasingly turning to
online streaming platforms to watch
these movies but this poses a challenge
what happens when they travel their
subscriptions often stop at the border
if I know sheet or assistant qiyamah
tell a mobility aid well apakah la
possibility irresolute problem the
pressure relative it reality methodology
photo program la mobility program aquel
wizard double Avenida would be no limit
after a final vote this month Parliament
will make it possible for consumers to
temporarily stream the same music shows
or movies anywhere in the EU see visible
tape example I might make a whistle a
avec on sodium avoid familia travail on
a spine Li service the curva survey the
Dhoni on Alman vous pouvez legacy does
not dissolve a veteran or not practical
media history text who while also
introducing new platforms will be able
to check their subscribers country of
residence for instance by asking for a
tax statement or phone bill spending on
digital video has grown exponentially in
recent years and 60 percent of young
Europeans expect to access their online
content wherever they go
[Music]
you
[Music]